Peter Bergen is a national security
expert and author of the new book Trump
and his generals the cost of chaos it
focuses on the relationship between the
president the national security
establishment and the rest of the world
Peter Bergen good morning welcome thanks
for being here good morning let's start
with this military training program that
the Saudi gunman was participating in
what can you tell us about that program
well you know the US and Saudis have
long had very close relationships
militarily
I mean what's interesting to me is we're
now sending thousands of American
soldiers to Saudi Arabia's after a
hiatus of more than a decade to what
extent are they being protected from
potential attacks in the kingdom and
this guy seems we don't know if this guy
radicalized before he arrived well while
he was here maybe a bit of both but
clearly it shows by the way this is the
first time a foreign national has
carried out a terrorist attack if indeed
it is terrorism one American soil since
9/11 terror attacks since 9/11 in Vera
be American citizens or legal permanent
residents so here we have a foreign
national by the way not part of the
travel ban countries Saudi Arabia
obviously so presumably he was vetted
pretty carefully before again yeah but
not sufficiently president Trump has
faced criticism for his reaction he put
out the condolences from the Saudi
Kingdom ahead of the facts that were the
result of a u.s. investigation what do
you make of that reaction well I mean
look the house of Trump and the House of
Saud are very close yes and I mean this
is you know they're all in with the
House of Saud and Mohammed bin Salman
the crown prince so it's not surprising
this is Trump's reaction do the thought
experiment where this was a Yemeni
rather than a Saudi I think his reaction
would be different you know the
president campaigned on pulling out of
Afghanistan yet he's now committed to
our presence there why is that
significant to you well he's gone back
and forth I mean right now you know he's
talked about peace talks to the Taliban
and that you stopped them that he said
he was recently in Afghanistan he said
we're gonna start them again he wants to
draw down he's a you know he's been a
skeptic of the Afghan project so he's
sort of he's had a bit sort of bit of a
mixed message about the Afghan policy
Peter I'm gonna get your reaction to a
Washington Post story that just dropped
so I'm gonna read a little bit of the
story and then get your thoughts so The
Washington Post has obtained nearly
2,000 pages of internal government
documents detailing
US officials misled the public about the
war in Afghanistan the Post reports a
three-star Army General who served as
the White House's Afghan Wars art during
the Bush and Obama administrations told
government interviewers in 2015 about
the war quote what are we trying to do
here we didn't have the foggiest notion
of what we were undertaking you know I
was in Afghanistan last week and you
know the place is quite different than
it was even ten years ago I mean we
traveled only an armored car it's
impossible to get out the security
situation in Kabul the capital is really
pretty bad you see a lot of tea walls
which are these 20-foot blast resistant
walls that you didn't see it it sound
right to you that the US mission was a
drift well we've had multiple different
missions I mean the joke about
Afghanistan there kind of board that
kind of it's not really a joke but the
observation there's you know we fought
18 wars there every year we kind of have
a new war with people then what kind of
new strategies so but you know that said
I mean look half the population now can
work half the population can now be
educated that wasn't true under the
Taliban for all the things that have
gone wrong there are some things that
have gone right which we can't forget
this this report though suggests that US
officials basically were hiding what it
calls unmistakable evidence the war had
become unwinnable well the US military
is a can-do organization is obvious
going to put the best gloss on what it's
doing so is that deception or is that
trying to put the best gloss on what
it's doing clearly this report this
report in the post is a big deal and I
think we'll raise questions about how
we've approached this it's interesting
that you have the the title the word
chaos in your title of this book because
reading it seems very appropriate Trump
and his generals the cost of chaos you
point out he's the first US president
who never had military public public
public service experience yet he was
very dead set on having generals in his
cabinet that didn't work out so well for
him did it well but I think he needed
the generals John Kelly who was a
four-star Marine General Jim Madison
well I mean they he listened to them and
I think they argued with him and
eventually they got rid of they either
resigned were forced out or just laughed
because they couldn't no longer have a
relationship with him so you know what's
left I think is much less impressive
group of people I mean I'm not saying
that some of them are you know serious
people but I
as safe as a result well it's a good
question I mean I mean the Ukraine
incident kind of speaks for itself in
the sense that the President Trump may
not have gone down that road if he'd had
a group like HR McMaster as natural
security adviser a chief of staff John
Kelly I mean these people were kind of
trying to put guard rails up and now
Trump is sort of unplugged in the
crystal the job general McChrystal who
declined a cabinet position yep
Secretary of Defense Peter Bergen thank
you very much
good to see you Trump in his generals
the cost of chaos goes on sale tomorrow